foreign
s us up next in San Diego Robert welcome
to the show
hello can you hear me we can loud and
clear what's going on all right so
basically I was calling because I uh I'm
kind of going around in circles with my
debt and you know it's all it's all my
fault but I don't quite know how to fix
it so in a nutshell I'm about forty
thousand dollars in the hole and you
know I've borrowed money to try to cover
some other money that I've borrowed and
and some of it's from gambling right and
trying to impulsively get money that way
to cover money that I've borrowed and I
you know but I'm not an addictive like I
don't I do it like once every three
months with that impulse trying to fix
debt right because I have no other way
to get money other than my job and so
I'm just going around in a circle
essentially
and it's just bad you know I know like I
have to stop the the one gambling
obviously that's stupid but
there's just no other way to make any
money are you married
yeah have you talked to your spouse
about this for accountability yeah yeah
yeah yeah no she knows she's done it
with me we're just in a bad spot but yes
okay what kind of debt is a forty
thousand well so 30 000 in a school loan
forever ago that I've got to start
paying right and then uh I've got about
uh 4 000 and just loans just personal
loans yeah but they're the interest
rates that are 100 you're talking like
payday payday loans
yes horrible okay number One never step
foot in one of those places again no
obviously but I just it's it's you're
right it's just trying to cover
it's like I had to keep borrowing to fix
stuff that I've messed up no you and and
that's what we want to change today you
don't have to keep borrowing and you're
okay we gotta when when you're in the
cycle like this you've got to draw a
line in the sand no more you cannot
borrow your way out of debt it's
impossible you can't solve a problem
while simultaneously creating it that's
thing one you have got to sit down with
your wife no more borrowing money two no
more gambling gambling is entertainment
for you I'm not I'm not gonna lie to you
if you're doing this every three months
and you're trying to do it as a strategy
I don't know if it's medication for you
stop gambling and if you're having
trouble with that let's get with a
professional on that so those that's
thing one thing too super duper
important I heard you say a couple of
things that I you know you said there's
no other way for me to make money and
that's just not true what are you
earning right now currently
115 a year okay just you or is that your
wife as well no she yeah together we
probably make like I don't know 106 this
is net
gross this is like we probably make yeah
we probably make uh probably make like
180 a year all right so what I can hear
from this 180 a year with 40 000 in debt
you guys are just spending man
understood but some of it we are I no no
question there I mean most of this is
well actually all of it is my debt that
I've I've occurred does she have debt
but no okay do you guys have any savings
it's prior to say that again do you have
any savings
oh if I did I wouldn't be doing all this
no okay so you have no money in the bank
we're living paycheck to paycheck making
180 000 a year I'm just saying it all
out loud so you can hear it too yeah
because I think we need to feel the pain
more because you're self-aware you're
going hey I know this is stupid I know
this is dumb I'm not I'm not gambling
anymore but you want to get out and that
takes a point where you have to say I'm
looking in the mirror going that guy's
the problem and he's the solution and he
makes way too much to be this broke man
correct so here we gave you the first
two kind of in inward things I'm not
borrowing money I'm gonna stop gambling
practically you've got to get on a
budget today and it's a great time
because we're getting ready to go into
May so we can start creating a budget
for the month of May look you have
enough money the good news is you earn
enough money you don't need to like go
out and find a new career like some
folks do you earn enough money your next
paycheck covers the payday loan it's
gone yeah
yeah but my rents do how much is your
rent
2400. you make 10 grand take home
where's the other seventy six hundred
dollars no I don't I don't make ten take
home you said you made 180 Grand a year
no no that's the Oh you mean between
both of us yeah because at this point I
understand that's I've paid some stuff
off too
I paid a prior loan off so what what's
left you got the payday loan 30 in
student loans where's the other six
that's another private loan so 3 500 a
private loan and then the rest are the
uh the uh payday loans okay what is your
next paycheck going to be
when it's going to be Wednesday know how
much how much
it'll be thirteen hundred dollars
money she's gonna get it she gets a
thousand dollars every Friday every week
great so we're gonna have 2 300 bucks in
the next week coming in
yes and rent's not quite due right no
it's past due you haven't been paying
rent because they're not on a budget
George look look I've been I've been
paying I've just been paying late
exactly and this is a merry-go it's
because there's no organization here you
guys get money and you spend it you get
money you spend it and you exactly so
there's no cash flow you've got to get
on a budget I want Austin to pick up
after this call you're going to get an
every dollar budget and it's going to be
the you're going to need to pay for the
premium version because you need to
start planning how your paychecks are
spent the first the first thing is
getting down all both of your incomes
combined because we're doing this
together you're married and we're gonna
spend every single Dollar on paper
before the month of May even begins then
we're going to go back through and we're
going to plan when we actually spend the
money so we know if rent is due on the
first of the month that comes out on the
first of the month but we still have the
right amount of money in order to do
everything else that we need to do does
that make sense you make the budget and
then you plan when you actually spend
the money in the budget and that's my
question yeah it makes perfectly good
sense but because I'm in this cycle and
I'm like three weeks behind right yep
that's on the rent I'm gonna pay the
rent the next uh Monday and then the
following week she's gonna let me do two
different checks right so then when the
first comes around I'm not going to have
the money yet because I just will have
paid all this money towards that and
then payday loans are due again so what
we'll do what you're going to do cut
into my check what you're going to do
first off when you do the budget we're
going to make minimum payments on
everything okay just minimums and then
with with any and all extra money we're
gonna hit we're gonna make sure we get
the mortgage listed first you said
you're three months behind on the
mortgage no no no no three weeks three
weeks okay so let's get current on all
the bills we're behind on what else
other than the rent are you behind on
uh just the electricity but I can tell
you that that's not that big a deal and
then uh
I've got a I am in a bankruptcy
currently but I pay that every month
it's chapter 13 so that's going to be
coming up on the 10th but I tell you
that I don't miss that
um and then I'm just behind on these uh
this loan I want to get I want to pay it
off you guys got kids Robert
I have a child with my other wife Matt
okay I think you both need to go to
Gamblers Anonymous because I think you
don't think it's as serious of a problem
as it is everyone listening is going
these people make two hundred thousand
dollars and they filed for bankruptcy
because they're in this payday lender
cycle it doesn't have to be this way man
hang on the line we're going to send you
every dollar premium use the paycheck
planning tool net to help you get on
board and we're going to send you
Financial Peace University both of you
go through this together scorched Earth
We're not eating out no expenses we are
getting a plan to get this money paid
off this is the Ramsay show